hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from round five of the
super bet chess classic it's constantine
lupulesco versus shakti armadyaro we
haven't had a game uh by shock in
quite some time now so hope you guys are
ready for it uh this one is uh
uh very very interesting uh and uh sorry
about the previous video
i asked my surgeon and he says that yes
the effects of
anesthesia are still very much visible
uh but yeah
that is not the last time fabi lost the
game in classical chess it was uh
actually to anish in the candidates
tournament so that being said uh thank
you for reminding me
uh now let's uh check out this game so
constantin with the white pieces opens
with
knight to f3 he goes for the ret opening
we have d5 e3
and now e6 we have c4 attacking the
center here
and now bishop to e7 we have b3
now preparing to fianchetto the dark
square bishop but uh black
attacks it uh attacks the rook
already on move four and this is a very
interesting uh
bishop maneuver it doesn't have a name
although it should have a name it's not
fiancarrowing the bishop this is fiance
the bishop
uh but this this does not have a name if
any of you
have an interesting name that we can use
uh make sure to suggest one
in the comments and we might implement
it from from the next video already
so here uh the rook is under attack of
course we have the defended knights the
c3
knights the e7 by mohammed yarov and now
bishop to b2 we
have c5 now uh grabbing more space in
the center
and now there is one game from 1993
between borislav and kashyany katino
where c
capture sandify was played ifco was able
to win this game
but here we have queen to see to end it
is now already as
of move seven that we have a completely
new game so let's see how momodaro deals
with this uh idea
uh we have uh knight b to c6 he just
continues development
and now comes knight to a4 and already
white is posing problems for black
because the c5 pawn is under attack
and you are threatening to pick up the
bishop and mess up a black spawn
structure the problem with eliminating
the bishop first is that
white can just play queen capture some
b2 and now the g7 pawn and the c5 pawn
are both under attack so you're going to
lose a pawn here
uh so instead after knight to a4 uh we
have b6 by mommy are just defending this
pawn and allowing the doubling of the
uh of the pawn so bishop captures on f6
g
captures and now c captures and e5 uh we
have queen captures on d5 you could
capture with the pawn but then your
uh king side the defense is uh well
non-existent basically
so here we have queen captures on d5 and
now knight
back to c3 uh getting the knight back
into the game uh with an attack on the
black queen
so queen to h5 and now uh lupulisco just
goes knight to e4 he's
threatening knight captures on f6 and
then he's going to win the queen
because the king and queen will be under
attack
at the same time so here we have queen
g6 now pinning the knight as the queen
on c2 would hang
and now comes knight to h4 uh here you
could go for
for knight the d6 check it looks like a
very uh
very uh well interesting idea but uh
after
king d7 the your knight is under attack
and also your queen is under attack so
you don't really have a good option here
you have to trade queens and then either
capture here or maybe play knight e4 go
after the pawn
but after black defense it's really not
a problem it's just a very very nice
position for black
uh so instead after uh queen to g6 we
have knight to h4
now again attacking the black queen now
all of these squares are taken away from
the black queen
so you have to play queen to h6 which is
not a problem it comes with an attack on
the knight and
now knight the d6 with check so here you
have to be a little bit careful you can
play something like this otherwise
you're just going to get knight captures
an f7 check without with a nice monster
fork here
so instead after knight the d6 check we
have king to f8
uh and here uh you have to decide do you
want to capture here or do you want to
play something like
g3 defend your knight and then maybe try
and play this game
uh seems also like a viable option uh so
in the game lupulesco decided to
eliminate the bishop first
we have rook captures on c8 and now
comes
g3 defending the knight we have rook to
d8
uh grabbing hold of the d for square
also if needed maybe you can uh bring
the rook into the game
via rook to d5 maybe we can play some
like king g7 rook d6 or d5 get this rook
into the game
uh double up on the d file a lot of
options uh here
so here we have bishop to e2 now the
playskool
is maybe interested in castling and king
to g7 now
now the rooks can be doubled here for
example on the d
file uh and now while white wants the
castle it could be a little bit
dangerous
because if white castles then we can go
knight g6 and now
you're threatening to just bust open the
king's defenses uh or if white captures
then you're gonna capture with the h1
and then have a nice queen rook battery
here to attack the white king with
so white would have to go back you don't
really want to trade here and then you
we just continue rook d6 rook h to d8
and so on
so black doesn't really have anything to
worry about here but a white instead
decides to wait he plays a3
takes away the b4 square from the black
knight and now comes
rook to d6 now mommy jarv might be
interested in doubling up on the d
file uh we have f4 uh really preventing
this queen from uh
entering the game anytime soon because
this is covered by the bishop discovered
by the pawn discovered by the knight so
this queen is not going anywhere anytime
soon
so rook h to d8 and now comes rook to d1
the d2 pawn is under attack and even
though
uh you don't really want to give up uh
two rooks for a queen
uh here in in a position that's this
close the
and you have two knights it would it
would probably be a good idea
so instead rook to d1 just defending
that pawn and
now comes f5 and f5 is uh one of those
moves that uh
you have to know what you're doing to
play it because if you if it
if it doesn't work yeah it's just a
weakening move you simply allow
these two squares for example for for
the white knights to use
uh but uh to come up with a move like f5
you have to
visualize where your pieces um uh where
do you want your pieces to be
uh you have to visualize this knight on
e4 and if you like this
then yeah you can play a move like f5
because now after f5 what uh mamidarov
did is basically he planned
knight to d5 to f6 and then he will have
access to e4
and then you can do the same with the
other knight then the other knight will
take its place knight to e7 to d5 to f6
and then for example to g4
so f5 really just is a move that allows
you to improve both of your knights
so here we have knight to f3 white also
will use the space left behind now the
g5 and e5 squares
are available to the white knight
knights to d5 and
now comes castles finally
we have king the g8 now getting the king
away from this uh
diagonal you don't want to run into any
checks anytime soon
and now comes rook to b1 uh we have a5
mommy are now really grabs hold of this
b4 square and now
bishop to b5 uh not uh not much to look
at more of a more of a waiting move uh
we have knight back at the e7 because
these knights are very very strong or
rather they will be very strong so if
you could maybe trade your bishop for
one of them
could be it might be a good idea even
though your pawns are on dark squares
then your light square bishop is an
excellent defender here
uh you simply know that the knights will
become uh
very very powerful so knight c to e7
uh continuing with his plan and now rook
f to d1
uh we have knight to f6 now the knight
has access to these two squares
and bishop back to f1 we have knight to
g4
and now it's a very very unpleasant you
you can never move this spawn anywhere
because this pawn falls you can't
move this knight because then this pawn
falls so it's
very hard to play this with white it's
still okay with perfect play you can
still hold the butt
it's a very very ugly to play this so
here bishop to g2 is fine you could play
this and then
i just claim that the black does not
have an active plan and black will
probably
play something like queen queen back
here you're gonna push the h pawn maybe
bring the knight to g6 and try to bust
open the the king's side
and the white will of course uh try to
prevent this but
uh in the game h3 was played and even
though h3 might be playable
uh if bishop to g2 is playable then you
play bishop to g2 maybe h3
uh h3 is just the weakening of your
kings side and you
i it's just uh already a very small
victory for black a small one but
it's still a victory so knight to f6 now
you have created a target here also this
is the second target it's going to be
very easy to attack this one
uh we have d3 and now comes knight to c6
uh you will have support for for pushing
e5 in the future
uh we have rook to e1 and now queen to
g7 putting pressure on the g3 pawn
uh we have queen to f2 defending it and
now
king the h8 the king no longer needs to
fear
this diagonal and now you are going to
double up here on the g file and
make this pawn a really vulnerable
target so here queen
king to h2 we have rooked the g8 putting
more pressure here for the moment it's
defended but
black will uh try to do something about
this
so here bishop to e2 making room for the
rooks to also join the defense
along the g file and now knight to d5 so
here uh the knight is a very very
unpleasant piece puts pressure on e3
pressures the c3 pawn it's going to
attack the bishop and the rook here
and it's hard to play a move for example
e4 uh loses on the spot the knight c3
now the rook is under attack and also
this pawn is under attack
so you're going to play rook to c1 but
now pawn captures here attacks the
knight and once you capture here then
knight captures
attacks the queen there is now a triple
attack on the g pawn this is resigns for
white
so instead after knight to d5 we have
bishop back to f1
and now comes e5 breaking through here
in the center
uh so it's a very tricky move and it
allows
white to defend but it's uh it's so ugly
to play to play this with white
uh in the game f captures on e5 was uh
if captures an e5 was played but
this doesn't work uh what you should
have done is play knight
to h4 but even this is very very hard to
play the problem is
after e captures on f4 you don't have
this knight capture so with an attack on
the queen and the rogue because here you
have just pawn captures on g3 with
check and you don't have a good move you
have to trade now we're going to just
trade here
captures captures and now knight to the
e5 and everything is hanging here
the material is completely equal here
but uh
white is just completely busted for
example bishop to g2
uh doesn't really matter knight to c3
attacks the rook here once the rook
moves you're just going to pick up this
pawn attack both of the rooks and that's
just it for example captures captures
and the white is just demolished so what
you would have to do here
after this knight the h4 idea and after
a move like e captures an f4 you would
have to capture back
just e captures on f4 and then try and
play this position where you now are
threatening this
but we're going to play some like queen
to d4 and then the game continues so
it's very hard for white
but it was his best chance however like
i said in the game
after e5 f captures and e5 was played
but now uh black is just completely
winning so feel free to pause the video
here uh
and figure out this incredible idea
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
well a very spottable move if i do say
so myself and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's rook to g6
now it might seem like an obvious idea
because uh you see that the g3 pawn
cannot be defended
now the reason why i think lupulesco
allowed this and did not go for the line
that we've shown
is that he probably calculated one move
differently he thought okay knight's the
h4
and now he thought that rook captures on
g3 was impossible because he had knight
captures on f5
but he doesn't here after mahmoud played
rook captures on g3
he realized he does not have knight
captures on f5 because knight captures
on f5
although uh looks incredible loses on
the spot so
once again pause the video here and find
a refutation tonight f5
while i again give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations for the second
time
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's the incredible
rook to f3 this is what i believe
lupulescu missed and
this is uh why he uh allowed mommy of
the tripling
on the on the g file because now you
don't have a move if you capture the
rook then queen to g1 is checkmate if
you don't capture the rook
uh well what do you do you could capture
the queen but it doesn't matter
rook captures on f2 comes with check and
now oh
it doesn't matter you you could attack
the rook we're just going to move the
rook and now the knight hangs here you
can't move the knight the knight is
pinned
and if you don't do this if you just
block with the bishop well then we
capture this one
uh right away and then again we're just
up a piece you cannot capture here the
the the bishop is pinned and there's
there's just no playing this
you could defend but knight captures on
e3 adds a third attacker to the g2 or g2
bishop
so uh here just everything loses and
this is what i believe
that happened so lupulesco missed this
and now it doesn't really matter what he
plays he's completely lost he played the
d
d4
in the game but now just uh uh here we
have queen to g5
attacking the knight here knight to g2
and now
c captures on d4 there's really not all
that much here uh that lupulescu can do
he played he captures on d5
4 but now just knight capture sandy for
offering yet
more material uh and he was in this
position almost 38
that constantine lupus who resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here
here we resign because knights the f3 is
coming and there's no defense against
this if you
if you grab the knight then just rook
capture some g to check
if you capture queen captures with
checkmate if you move then we'll just
play
rook to g1 check again if king h2 queen
to g3 is checkmate if you capture the
rook then queen captures and g1 is
checkmate
so that does not work and uh another
thing
if you don't grab the knight if you just
uh you know play anything
other than this try and add another
defender here uh just knight f3 check
and that's it you either give up the
queen or you play king to h1
uh the knight covers g1 and h2 both uh
and not just rook captures and h3 is
checkmate so
that's it so great game by lupulescu and
the great tournament for him so far but
he
uh ran into a most unpleasant opponent
now mamidyarov uh
uh really uh won this one in great style
and it's uh
you see how he constantine played the
really really fighting chess he wanted
to
uh take uh uh take mamidarov head on and
he allowed him to to you know go after
him but he miscalculated that one move
again
what is i i believe is what happened uh
but yeah
that's just you know things happen and
especially it's very nice when things
happen in in classical chess
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it uh currently in the lead after five
rounds are
westley saw alexander grishok uh and um
uh he ha uh grisha had a long struggle
against uh diac
he really really played many many moves
to take him down
uh but yeah the romanian grandmasters
are playing a brilliant tournament and
it really
takes a lot for these uh these monsters
to take them down
uh and the mamidarov so grisha questly
so and mommy are currently leading the
tournament but we'll see what happens
more rounds to go
so i'm not going to discuss the results
of the other games from round five i
might cover
a few more uh so we'll see what happens
so once again hope you guys enjoyed it
i would like to thank michael hildebrand
steven mcgoh uh mario and sinosa rick
evano
and stanley hill for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day